[موسيقى]
بجناحين يطوفان على السماء وشموخ يسر
الناظرين يطير الصقر في الاجواء باحثا عن
تحدي جديد سواء كان هجره او فريسه اخرى
الصقر واحد من رموز الثقافه العربيه
الداله على شموخ
وفي مصر القديمه كانت للصقر حكايات
واساطير يصل بعضها لحد التقديس هو ابن
الالهين ايزيس وازوريس انه حورس الىه
العدل والخيل انه الاله حامي ابيه الذي
فقد عينه في معركه اخذ ثار ابيه ثم صار
ملكا لكل مصر
ان تزكي حب البشر واجلاله من الصقور منذ
ابد الدهر وعشق الصقور في مصر والعالم
العربي لم يتوقف عبر الازمان فما زال كثير
من المصريين والعرب ينظرون للسقر في فخار
واعجاب خاصه البدو
البدو يعني كعشق الصدور حاجه حاجه اكيده
متاكده يعني ان هم كلهم
اعتزاز عندهم حتى غير الصقار اللي هو برده
في طريقه شغله وبتاع بس تلاقيه عنده مخصص
وقت دايما للصغار
[موسيقى]
سافرنا الى احدى صحاري مصر انه عائشه
السقاريين
وذلك اثناء ممارستهم هويتهم ولنا نلتقي من
يتركون بيوتهم لايام طويله وربما لاشهر
ليحسد الصيد الثمين
وسيد الصقور او السجاره ممارسه متوارثه
بين كثير من العرب حيث يبدا الاطفال
تعلمها منذ الثامنه حتى يعتاد على الصقور
فيالف كل منهما الاخر
اول شهر عشره اكتوبر مخيم حط الخيمه وننزل
بالحمام
والشرق وينزلوا معي من اول شهر 10 غير شهر
12 صغير
[موسيقى]
زي ما الناس تروح تصيف وحاجه اساسيه عندها
احنا عندنا موسم الصيد ده حاجه اساسيه
لازم يطلع الصوت ثلاث شهور خيم في الصحراء
ونولع الحطب ونولع ونعمل الاكل على الحطب
وكده دي حاجه عندنا دي حاجه اساسيه
بتاعتنا